[Music]
hey guys the second episode of the final
season just ended and it was amazing
before we make breakdown on Episode
three preview let's firstly review the
season 8 episode 2 before the opening
scene of James trial we see the new
ensure that now changes every episode
the ice floor that spreads out from the
wall presenting the night King and his
army who bring the storm and winter that
in the premiere event to discard the
seat of house amber and for Cheryl its
doom now goes to NFL from the entry
itself we already knew for a fact that
in I Kings army would arrive at
Winterfell by the end of episode two the
episode begins with James trial which I
have to say disappointed me a bit and
I'll tell you why but also gave quite a
few hints that going favor to Tyrion
being a trader and working for Cersei
then he says to Jaime how her late
brother Viserys used to tell her bedtime
stories about the man who killed her
father
as well as about what they would do to
that man after they take back the Seven
Kingdoms Jaime reveals told them that
Cersei has betrayed them she's not
sending her arm snort additionally she
has brought the gun and company to fight
against them after the Great War is over
what I expected next to happen is Dan is
saying that she shared the same
intentions with her brother regarding
Jaime until she found out what Jaime
actually killed her father which was to
stop him from burning all the innocent
people of King's Landing but no then he
still wants to kill Jaime and it's only
until sense and John's say that it's
okay that they only decides not to
execute Jaime yes in case you missed a
tear and told the anyway Jaime killed
her father in the ninth episode of the
sixth season when discussing a plan to
deal with the slaver fleet that was at
the time besieging their city of murine
then he declared the plan to destroy the
maesters armies kill them all and
destroyed our cities
Tyrion disapproves and explained the
similarities between this plane and the
one her father had for the King's
Landing when the Lancers were at his
door
Tyrion also said that the only reason
his brother Jaime killed her father was
because the Mad King wanted to burn the
city to the ground along with its
population so then he already knows the
truth behind Jaime so-called betrayal
over her father and it's definitely hard
for her to want to punish him for that
even she herself admitted her father was
an evil man back in season seven when
meaning chance now tyrion speaks for
jamie saying your grace i know my
brother but then his quick to cut him
off with like you knew your sister
nevertheless tyrion continued by saying
he came here alone knowing full well how
he would be received why would he do
that if he weren't telling the truth
then he is still not convinced it even
sends a supporter or at least until
brian vouches for jamie as expected
jamie shocked face from episode to
preview turn out to be upon hearing
something from brain Jamie doesn't
regret what he's done against how stark
because he had to do it for the good of
his family saying he'd do it all over
again which is a brain says to him the
things we do for love the same line
Jamie said to brain before pushing him
out the window
this obviously has Jamie shocked Jamie
now knows full well that brain remembers
but he also knows that brain clearly
chose not to tell anyone else because if
he had Jamie would have likely been
sentenced to death we later find out
brain did not tell them because Jamie
will have an important role in this war
Danny asked seems so why did you abandon
your house and family now to beat Jamie
replied to it because this goes beyond
loyalty as he looks at Brienne
this is a callback to the season 7
finale when Brian told Jamie foil tea
this goes beyond houses saint-honore
notes which help Jamie realize it's all
about the Great War which is why he
abandoned Cersei
Brienne vouches for Jamie and real
sweaters that he defended her from the
people who tried to force themselves
upon her which is the reason Jamie lost
his hand Brienne also reveals the sensor
that his the reason she's even alive
is this Jamie who were armored her armed
her and sent her on a quest to find her
fulfilling an oath he gave to her mother
Catelyn
after hearing all of this since
ourselves Jamie should stay because
bring Justin there's some tension
between John and Danny john cannot even
look at her at this meeting which we all
know why John agrees with science and
the decision is made
Jamie fights for them now John leaves
the Great Hall without speaking to her
then it does not look happy because
Tyrion messed up again then is made that
Tyrion because Cersei betrayed him and
he is in her mind either a fool or a
traitor for persuading them all to
believe his sister - which Tyrion is
quick to admit he's a fool but is he
really
are we supposed to believe since I could
spend far less time in search they was
able to tell Cersei was not going to
send help north but their answers his
brother and once Cersei actually talked
about is believed her
I think Tyrion and Cersei made a deal in
the season 7 finale in Tyrion betrayed
Danny at the end of the scene then he
says to him if you can't help me or
throw your sister and bring me the Iron
Throne
then I'll find a hand who can in turn
his response to that is I suspect one of
you will be wearing this referring to
the hand of the queen pin and before
it's all over
many foreshadows here Genji and Arya
talk about the White Walkers
Genji once argued to be down in the
crypts when the dead actually arrived
but arias quick to change his mind by
displaying her skills ginjuries right
back on making a weapon for Arya Jamie
finds brain to talk to him apologizing
for what he's done to him but brain is
not angry because if Jamie had not done
it then Jamie would not have changed and
would not have been here helping them
and he still would have been Brandon
Stark and not the three-eyed Raven Jamie
asked if he'll tell the matter words
which brain responds with how do we know
there's a net words which is either for
sharing James death in the great war
against the nine king's army or the
death of all the humanity when FL is in
the midst of preparation making all
defenses and weapons out of journalist
Jamie and Tyrion finally have a proper
reunion
Tyrion says kids made mistakes Jamie
says Cersei is pregnant for real that
thing on the walls behind them is
reckless which will come handy when the
dead try climbing the walls
let me hear once again how Tyrion would
like to die
the same description we already heard
multiple times and so did Jamie Jamie
notices Brienne who's training soldiers
and will command the left flank Brienne
has come a long way Podrick has come a
long way as well and seemingly became a
great warrior in his own right the dead
are doomed
Jaime says he would be honored to serve
under brilliants command a bit emotional
scene and from the official trailer we
know the two will fight side by side
then we have a conversation between
Danny and Jorah
jor-el's Dany that she broke his heart
when she named Tyrion the hand but he
also says that she made the right choice
then he says Tyrion made serious
mistakes but Jorah tells her she should
forgive Tyrion as everyone makes
mistakes and learns from them the jar
makes another suggestion for his queen
have a conversation with the lady of
NFL's Sansa Stark and come in good terms
then he finds inside the to have a
conversation then he says she thought
sense and her were on the verge of
agreement about Jaime before brain
changes senses mind the kind of advisor
she'd like to have the one who she can
trust and since ice quick to say that
Tyrion is a good man and a good choice
for the hand sensor says they hear John
in common but at men tend to do stupid
things for love then he says she always
wanted throne but now she's fighting
Jones more she's here because she loves
him
Sansa says she should have thanked Danny
right away they joke about yoga he's
taller than John the two finally come to
good terms but incense is Danny what
will be with the north a third a defeat
dead
insert seven she takes the on throne
implying that she wants it to be an
independent Kingdom which is where the
two are back at it again with all the
tension mr. vulcan interrupts the
conversation and the ingredients with
his arm born it's a heartbreaking scene
film comes to fight for his home for
vana fell and the Lady of NFL accepts a
metal heart this is a huge moment for
Theon and the Starks as well fiance
brings life back in season one from
weddings but then a bit later he was the
reason brain had to flee Winterfell I
believe the universe a brain again or
maybe sense at this time with his bow
and he might even die while doing it
then we see good like the Dallas feeling
people and encouraging newcomers Gillis
says either ladies we're going to hide
during the battle for Vina fell in the
crypts saying it's the safest place to
be but is it really from season one
conversation between mr. Vulcan and
Theon Greyjoy we learned that their
hidden passages in the crypts the lead
to the outside its walls built for the
Starks so they can escape in the case of
emergency
what if the knight King was a stark is
that why we don't see him outside with
his army
is he leading a small force to attack
Winterfell from inside the crypts I do
think so and I don't think this brave
little girl will be able to protect
those in the crypts but the night king
shows up out of nowhere at barrack in
torment arrival NFL and his Iranian with
his former Nights Watch brothers John
and Sam internment his reunion with his
favorite crow John generous would happen
with the Lascar two numbers Janice how
long do we have
tormund replies with before the Sun
comes up tomorrow door counsel is called
upon and pretty much everyone important
is there as John says they're coming we
have general as similarly in steel but
there are too many of them
far too many our enemy doesn't tire
doesn't stop doesn't feel as a Savannah
fella
armoring up and arming its people
defenses are as ready as much as they
can be
did the Cherokee Indian sullied march
outside John continues by saying we
cannot beat them in the street fight and
Jamie asked so what we can do
John share so they learned on their
mission beyond wall if you kill the one
who raised the mold they all die
pointing out that killing the knocking
is their main object but killing by
walkers is also pretty good as all the
ways they raised die along brandon
wheels that a knocking is coming for him
and that might be their best chance to
kill him
brain is marked brain has made his
decision he will stay out there in the
open in the godswood of interval to
basically be a bait for the night king
Thea will be protecting him with his arm
bored protecting Winterfell on the left
flank we have combined forces of the
Starks and the Knights of the Vale on
the right flank only the northerners in
the metal we have Dana's armies the
unsullied ended the Trekkie inside the
wall secured forces of house moment that
will still be on the walls of interval
signalizing gutters and is the right
time to light the trench dragons will
apparently not be in the field because
they will have another desk protect
brain although they're not sure if
dragon fire can actually kill the knight
King John still cannot look Danny in the
eyes she can tell something has happened
Tyrion and brain have a long
conversation of screen he's saying they
agree won't talk about living after the
war this adds up to does this question
to me stand in season 7 and he asks her
if her queen will let her leave and go
home to which me sane I replied with yes
let's hope grave worm does not die in
the battle for NFL and the two actually
survived the events of Game of Thrones
finally we see ghosts and Jonny's same
talk about his parents Emma John plans
to tell Danny the truth former brothers
of the Nights Watch standing on the wall
with ghosts in the back and now their
watch begins
Jaime Tyrion talk and drink wine Brienne
and Podrick walk in Podrick wants to
drink a brain only allows him half a cup
since Darren and pod are old friends
during disobeys brilliance order Stanga
came full proper glass of wine devil
shows up as well in fact a lot of people
show up and some of them bring their own
booze it's quite a party Amina fell I
suppose it makes the army of the Dead
show party breakers one more serious
note it's nice to see the living have a
few moments of peace until the battle
begins roman talks about their nicknames
with jaime explaining why they call em
Giantsbane which is because he killed a
giant when he was 10 and that her dad
slept with his wife
after that tone spent three months with
her and she thought he was her baby
that's apparently the reason why he is
so strong giants milk next we have arya
joining the hound on the battlements
arya says she has changed and asked
again what is he doing here since he has
never fought for anyone but himself
Clegane tells her he fought for her once
which he sure did back then the hell did
not know Breen was there to help aria
especially with deadlines are stored
around her waist so he fought her to
defend Arya I like this scene a lot as
it not only shows how Arya became much
like the Hound but it also shows how
much the Hound cares for her we also
find barrack is not on arias death list
anymore
already decides to spend final hours
with someone else
she goes to ginjuries Forge and trains
for a bow for a while until Ginza shows
up with the weapon he's made for her
arya asks what did the red woman another
person who was but also still is on
arias list wanted for him which is when
she learns interest robert baratheon son
already knows that they're possibly
going to die soon and she wants to do
something she's never done before in
their final hours they kiss closer off
many things happen of screen we're done
back to huge gathering of many main
characters before the battle Tyrion
muses estranged her all their brain says
they'll at least die with honor they
joke about surviving a troll Brienne
explains to the room that she's not a
knight
because women cannot be Knights term
says if he were a king he would neither
Jamie says you don't need King as any
knight can make a knight and just like
that Jamie night sir Jamie knows this
because in the books he was knighted by
one of the best nights Westeros has ever
seen by Sir Arthur Dayne himself on the
battlefield after defeating the
Brotherhood we all know how much she
means to Brienne to be a knight and how
much she wanted it you know there's no
true knight as Brienne
so I'm glad she finally became one
however I'm worried for what it means or
better said what it foreshadows I'm
worried she might die a night death in
the next episode in a battle protecting
either some of the Starks or just some
innocent people as soon I does let's
hope she's rice in the courtyard of NFL
jaw tells Lena to go to the crypts but
she's not here for this she will fight
same stumbles upon them and gives Hearts
been to Jorah Sam says that jurors
fathered the old bear told him to be a
man and to do what is right giving the
sword to jurors right then they're once
again back to Knights and wine tasting
Jenny's song as the thing we see how
main characters spend their final hours
this is Sammy Gilley a little same sense
of a Fiona dinner game's avatar in bed
grave or made me stand a kiss before he
leaves the solid outside sure leads the
rest of the nice forces just as the song
finishes we see Danny joining join the
crypts hearing Jenny's song is quite a
big deal and might serve as a huge
foreshadow for later on in the season
especially for John and Danny for all of
you that don't know Jenny's song is
known among the game internals fans as a
song of the prince that was promised the
song is about Jenny of old stones and
her husband Duncan Targaryen the prince
of dragonflies an heir to the Iron
Throne who gave up his rights to it for
their love what is also interesting is
that Duncan much like John also had dark
hair
Jenny was friends with a would switch
who prophesied to the prince that was
promised to be born from the line of
Prince Aerys same Prince Rolla
Cordain his mother and father or John's
grandmother and grandfather Rhaegar
Targaryen OVA is related to the prince
that was promised the Song of Ice and
Fire
kind the hosts of the kings were gone
Jenny would dance for ghosts the song
says and it might foreshadow that John
will also give up his claim to the Iron
Throne for love for Danny but it might
also foreshadow that one of them will
die
speaking of the claim to the Iron Throne
then he learns in The Cribs that John's
claim is better as she learns her
brother and Lyanna Stark married in a
secret ceremony and had a baby that was
adopted by Ned Stark and his true
heritage was kept a secret and the baby
is Jon Snow then he is much like John
was at first shocked and in disbelief
before they could talk more about it the
horn is blown the nine king's army has
arrived it all the White Walkers leading
it except for the leader himself
King could he be coming through the
secret passage inside the novel perhaps
episode three will be one hell of an
episode and one cannot wait to see it
stay tuned for the episode three preview
breakdown and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next one peace